on a sunny july morning he should have
been at school with his friends
instead they waited for him here
his mother ready to bury her son d
john reed was just 14 when he was
stabbed to death here in birmingham
his family say he went to play football
and didn't come home
i couldn't believe that my little
brother is gone
you know i still don't believe now every
day i feel like
i see him like
to know that somebody just
take my brother's future away
it's just horrible man to see that
legion it's gone and it's not here
anymore
it is a lot for me and my son for
dijon's young friends it's tough
he's the second close friend pharrell
has lost to violence
i get a bunch of emotions at the same
time i get angry i get sad
but listen to this and bear in mind he's
just 15 years old
are you surprised when people get
murdered now
not not really because it's every day
underneath
somebody's dying like every day it's not
like
it happens right like it happens on a
regular basis now
so it's you can't really be shocked
it's like you it's like you know it's
it's like it's like it's you're
expecting it
he expects it because he's grown up
surrounded by it
his mum tells me about her older son
he's actually at the moment
serving a 12-year sentence for
aggravated robbery
he got um stabbed he's been shut up he
nearly lost his life last year
he then committed a crime people judge
me for what my son has done
but you know if we're not losing our
kids to graves we're losing them to a
prison system because there's no help in
between
in fact these mums tell me living here
it's just
too easy for kids to choose the wrong
path
the drug dealing goes on down here
younger children are getting involved
seeing older children
doing this making money real quick and
we would like to reduce that
we would like to reduce that and then
for them to protect themselves late at
night they feel like they have to carry
a weapon
they say that you've got three yards
one's the yard you live in one's a
prison yard
and one's a graveyard so that's
basically your free practicing life
each street has its own story this is
unfortunately where uh kian lost his
life
keon lincoln was 15 he was shot and
stabbed in the street outside his home
in january
heartbreaking because that could be our
child could be the next one
who's next it was dayton that was in
another another area
what's next are we waiting for the 13
year old then the 12 year old
it's like a pandemic because it's not
stopping they're on about the virus
but the kids are dying just as quick as
the virus is taking out people
and it's just mads they search for
somewhere their kids can go
something for them to do some way to
keep them off the streets
this could be massive we could do a
boxing gym that side
no more gym this was once a youth center
but look at it now
derelict dirty destroyed by years of
neglect
relics of the past buried beneath the
grim reality
of the present people feel forgotten
they feel like their children are dying
and nobody's listening
what are you going to do about it i
don't think any of us could imagine
there's anything more of a priority than
preventing young people being subject to
violent attacks on the street and killed
but also i think the community has a
role to play of being not
not feeling forgotten about but being
intolerant of this being challenging
in communities that it's not acceptable
sometimes being challenging to agencies
about what we're doing and holding us to
account
but nobody nobody's forgotten about this
issue because it's
so stark and so visible
everyone knows if it doesn't stop this
will keep happening
and more young lives will be lost becky
johnson sky news
birmingham